we found that a law existed when the
relation was such that the universal
organic property in an organic system
had made itself into a thing and in this
thing had a structured copy of itself so
that both were the same being present in
the one case as a universal moment and
in the other as a thing but in addition
the aspect of the inner is on its own
account also a relationship of several
aspects and we are therefore presented
to begin with with the conception of a
law as an interrelationship of the
universal organic activities or
properties whether such a law is
possible must be decided from the nature
of such a property this however as a
universal fluid is on the one hand not
something restricted like a thing
keeping itself to the restricted form
which is supposed to constitute its
shape sensibility extends beyond the
nervous system and permeates all the
other systems of the organism on the
other hand such a property is a
universal moment which is essentially
not divorced or separated from reaction
or irritability and reproduction for as
reflection into self at AO episode
contains reaction mere reflectiveness
into self is passivity or a dead being
not Sensibility just as action which is
the same as reaction when not reflected
into itself is not irritability it is
precisely the unity of reflection in
action or reaction and action or
reaction in reflection that constitutes
the organism a unity which is synonymous
with organic reproduction it follows
from this that in every mode of the
organisms actuality there must be
present the same quantity of sensibility
since to begin with we are considering
the
nation of sensibility and irritability
to one another as of irritability and
that an organic phenomenon can be
apprehended and determined or if you
like explained just as much in terms of
the one as of the other what one person
takes say for high sensibility another
may equally well take for high
irritability and irritability of the
same degree if they are called factors
and this word is not to be meaningless
they are thereby declared to be moments
of the notion thus the real object whose
essence is constituted by this notion
contains them both equally within it and
if the object is characterized according
to the one moment as very sensitive it
must also be stated according to the
other moment to be just as irritable
we're now in paragraph 270 roughly at
the halfway point in observing reason
and we've seen observing reason
attempting to find or formulate and then
also to explore the functioning or the
application as well as the underpinnings
of laura and laura is applied not just
to observing anything whatsoever but
particularly the organic being and
particularly the animal being it seems
that that observing reason has got
itself you might say caught up with
organic beings it's much more interested
in and attracted to them in part because
they're more complex and they're not
only more complex in this outer sense of
having you know various organs and
systems and things like that that we
don't see for example in the mineral
kingdom but there's something more
complex on a different level involved
there namely this what we've been
calling teleology the capacity for a
thing to be not only placed within a
context of ads but to be an end for
itself to in effect to be something like
a Hegelian notion that led us to seeing
that there's this inner to it and we
went through a whole interplay about you
know the inner itself he has an outer
which we're going to talk about here in
terms of thing and this this general
idea of the law applying to organic
beings as being that the outer is in
some way the expression of the inner now
Hagel is actually going to be removing
that and he's not simply canceling it
out he's going to show us where the
failures are rising to the surface where
things are breaking down so there's a
very long paragraph I don't have an
awful lot on the board I'm going to add
a bit more
go on but some of it is just stuff you
have to sort of keep in mind as we go
through this so he says we found a law
existed when the relation was such that
the universal organic property that's
the inner in this case in an inorganic
system outer had made itself into a
thing that you know it externalize
itself it expressed itself as he think
it's something observable and they says
in this thing had a structured copy of
itself so the thing here and the thing
here presumably had this relation of
mimesis of structural similarity or
something like that and so he says but
in addition the aspect of the inner is
on its own account also a relation of
several aspects here's where we started
running into problems so we've got this
Universal organic property let's call it
sensibility right and then we have
sensibility over here embodied in a set
of organs the eyeballs the nervous
system parts of the brain whatever we
want right and you know we can do
equally the same thing we could talk
about system of locomotion if we want it
to our feet and our if we crawl around
on our hands I suppose but in any case
he's saying there's a multiplicity here
it's a relationship of several aspects
and we are therefore presented with a
conception of law as an interrelation of
the universal organic activities or
properties so what is he talking about
there all right if we think about this
schema the notion of law has been
applying to the relation between the two
sides the outer and the inner but the
lower in order to really be law must
also be dealing with the relations
between this Universal org accessed
this universal organic system this
universal organic system you know we
don't want to say well we just have a
lot it only applies to Sensibility we
wanted to apply to all the functions of
the organism if it's indeed supposed to
be this comprehensive law or if you know
if you want to think of this less in
terms of what I think perhaps in terms
of an overarching account or theory some
sort of intelligible systematic way of
understanding now that doesn't seem to
be a bad thing of a problem on this side
does it why is it a problem for this
side well hey you'll tell us here he
says whether such a law is possible
notice what he's doing there he's
calling into question whether such a law
is it actually possible or not he's not
taking it for granted and saying that
must be possible you know people have
textbooks they have these sort of things
in them so let's just explain what's
happening when we you know formalize
this or human-sized this nothing's
saying maybe it's not really possible to
have a law in a strict sense that is
doing with the inner now did not even in
tier-ii ority of like consciousness but
the inner of an organic being so he goes
on enemy says this however as a
universal fluid is on the one hand not
something restricted like a thing we can
look to the organic being and you know
take a look for example at its various
systems of organs and those can be
arranged with each other those are
separate from each other right but when
we talk about this Universal fluidity
over here on the side of the inner we're
talking to men something a bit different
Hagel's going to end up saying
that these properties are not hurts the
way that these organs or systems are
there you know strictly speaking you
could say they interpenetrate each other
they occupy the same place it's sort of
like when Aristotle is talking about the
soul yeah the day on which I mentioned
in an earlier video Aristotle says that
yes we can distinguish between parts of
the soul in a certain way another way we
can't they're not parts like you know
pages in this book or the articles of
clothing that I'm wearing or even you
know the fingers on my hand they you
know they really are activities of the
soul and they are involved with each
other in a way different than merely
material objects or external material
objects so he says it's not something
restricted like a thing keeping itself
to the restricted form which is supposed
to constitute a shape sensibility to
take an example extends beyond the
nervous system and permeate all the
other systems of the organism that's
something worth dwelling on here Hagel
is saying sensibility has one of these
universal organic properties is not a
thing like a de markable part you know
something that can be separated from
from the other part so you can separate
the you know the systems of nerves I
suppose you know if you were
extraordinarily fine surgeon or you know
maybe we do some science fictiony stuff
and think about a machine that can do
that in the future but that's the that's
the external that's not the internal and
I want me an internal like your guts
we've already talked about that's a
visceral system right we mean what is
within the organism as a living thing so
it was allowed and he says here we go
sensibility extends beyond the nervous
system
permeates all the other systems of the
organism on the other hand such a
property is a universal moment which is
essentially not divorced or separated
from reaction or irritability and
reproduction now a little bit you know
later on of Hadel is going to suggest to
us that maybe these three aren't the
only games in town are not the only
activities the the key you know moments
as we're calling them here of the
organic being but let's say that they
are in this case what he's saying is
that sensibility is not something
strictly and rigidly distinguishable
from this other faculty or you know
activity function of irritability or
reproduction they permeate each other
they interpenetrate each other in
certain ways if you've ever read maurice
merleau-ponty who drew on hagel
merleau-ponty is phenomenology of
perception merleau-ponty is saying
something similar about the different
modalities in which or the different
dimensions in which we perceive things
for a normal living being perception is
actually a whole confluence of different
you might say perspectives all coming
together not harmoniously necessarily
but but into a synthesis Hagel is saying
that something like that happens within
the organism and that's what allows all
these systems to function together in a
living being so he goes on and he says
as a reflection into self this is
Sensibility it alien so contains
reaction why it says mirror
reflectiveness in the self or passivity
is a dead thing it's not a living thing
when we have organic beings and we're
attempting to observe them we're
attempting to observe them as living
beings because although they are made
out of organic materials they're no
longer an organism when they're dead
when they're no longer a functional
whole and so excuse me when you're
observing a dead thing a cadaver or a
sample or something like that you are
from Hagel's perspective not observing
the the organism itself he goes on and
he says it's precisely the unity of
reflection and action or reaction an
action or reaction in reflection that
constitutes the organism a unity which
is synonymous with organic reproduction
so what is he saying even in sensibility
which we took to be more passive than
irritability or reaction or action will
let alone reproduction which you know
constitutes another new peeing in
existence usually in place of the one
that's that's being left behind those
are that activity is involved already
insensibility why because this is not
just merely a closed-off hole this is a
self relation it is a as you said return
into soft so yoga's only says it follows
from this that in every mode of the
organisms actuality there must be
present the same quantity of sensibility
now that's an interesting thing to say
it's one thing to say that we're talking
about you know these these things inter
fusing with each other and being
connected with each other now he's being
very specific and saying sensibility has
to be the same quantity quantity is more
or less something on the external
right so he says since we're considering
the relation of sensibility and
irritability to one another there has to
be the same quantity of sensibility as
of irritability you don't get the one
without the other they're both there and
they're not just both there as qualities
they're there in terms of quantities
what we can measure what we can observe
enamel so he says what one person takes
for high sensibility another may equally
well take for high heritability and your
inability of the same degree if we want
to call these factors and this word is
not to be meaningless they are there i
declare to be moments of the notion what
what notion well he tells us the real
object whose essence is constituted by
this notion right so the notion is that
of organic being that of life living
thing so he says it contains them both
equally with it if the object is
characterized according to one moment is
very sensitive it must also be stated
according to the other moment to be just
as irritable now that's going to pose a
problem as we're going to see because if
we're saying that whatever is going on
here in its expression is not just a
bunch of disconnected than fortuitously
working together systems or organs or
something like that that we can measure
quantitatively but there's an intrinsic
connection that's coming from the thing
being a living thing what's going to
happen to that you know Faculty of
distinguishing and measuring horses
let's say facility with doing so that's
needed for the law well that's going to
be discussed in these paragraphs yet to
come
if they are distinguished as they
necessarily are this is in accordance
with the notion and their opposition is
qualitative but when apart from this
true difference they are also positive
as they immediately are and for ordinary
thought as they might be as aspects of
the law that only appear as
quantitatively distinct their peculiar
qualitative antithesis thus becomes one
of magnitude and there arise laws of
this kind for example that sensibility
and irritability stand in an inverse
ratio of their magnitude so as the one
increases the other decreases or better
taking that directly the magnitude
itself is content it's as its smallness
decreases should however a specific
content be given to this law say that as
the size of the hole increases the more
what it is filled with decreases then
this inverse relation can equally be
changed into a direct relation and
Express in this way that the size of the
hole increases in direct ratio to the
amount taken away a tautological
proposition whether expressed as a
direct or as an inverse ratio as so
expressed the proposition means simply
this that a quantity increases as this
quantity increases just as the whole and
what fills it and is taken away or
qualitatively opposed but what is real
in them in its and it's specific
quantity is one on the same in both and
similarly increase of magnitude and
decrease of smallness are the same and
they're meaningless antithesis amounts
to a tautology so are the organic
moments alike indivisible in their real
content and in their magnitude which is
the magnitude of that being the one
decreases only with the other it
increases only with it or rather it is a
matter of indifference whether an
organic phenomenon is considered as
irritable or a sensibility this is so in
general and equally when its magnitude
is under discussion similarly it is a
matter of indifference whether we speak
of the increase of a whole as an
increase of
emptiness or is an increase of the
filling removed from it or again a
number for example three remains the
same quantity whether it is taken
positively or negatively and if i
increase the three to four then both the
positive and the negative yet become for
just as the South Pole of a magnet is
exactly as strong as its north pole or a
positive electricity or an acid is
exactly as strong as its negative or the
base on which it acts an organic
existence is just such a magnitude as
the said three or a magnet that's and so
on it is that which is increased or
diminished and when it is increased both
of its factors are increased just as
both poles of the magnet or both kinds
of electricity increase with the
potential of a magnet or of one of the
electric currents is raised that both
can vary just as little an intention and
extension that the one cannot decrease
in extension but increase in intention
while the other conversely is supposed
to decrease its intention but extra but
increase its extension this stems from
the same notion of an empty antithesis
the real intention is absolutely as
great as the extension and vice versa
paragraph 271 is pretty long but it's
long primarily because in it when Hagel
is doing is giving you a lot of examples
to try to help you wrap your head around
the point that he's trying to make which
is ultimately this that as we're trying
to make sense out of these organic
functions from the perspective of
ordinary thought or the law that we've
been trying to work out what we get is
essentially a tautology and that's you
know not a bad thing in and of itself
but it's a dead end you could say when
you would arrive at a tautology either
you really wanted to get there in which
case great you've arrived but a
tautology means saying the same thing in
different ways saying the same thing
essentially twice so it's not quite sure
what you know it's not exactly clear why
you would want to get it it's not really
an achievement if you were trying to get
somewhere else if you were trying to
attain some sort of clarification or new
understanding and tautology is exactly
what you don't want it becomes instead
of just a dead-end a cul-de-sac where
you keep circling around right
cul-de-sac actually comes from the
bottom of bag right I can't get out of
the day so what do we mean by by all of
this let's start where Hagel starts he
says if their distinguished what does he
mean by their sensibility irritability
reproduction these these basic functions
of the organism this is in accordance
with the notion and their opposition is
qualitative there you can be
distinguished from each other
qualitatively right there's something
there now if we want to instead start
formulating them in terms of what what
natural science seems to demand the law
in this case some sort of comprehensive
theory of them he says what an apart
from this true difference they're
positive as they immediately
what does that mean immediately are as
they are externally there for ordinary
thought they as they might be as aspects
of the law they appear as quantitatively
to state so this is a very important
difference that Hagel brings up at many
points as a matter of fact they don't
want to dwell on this too long but this
is something that philosophers after
Hagel and also before Hagel have given a
lot of thought to Aristotle
distinguished between quantity and
quality as different categories right
and in his metaphysics it seems that
quality is in a certain way more
ontological II prior than than quantity
there's many other metaphysics in which
quantity is assumed to be what is truly
metaphysically prior as a matter of fact
that was a common movement he had in
modernity that was connected with the
rise of the modern sciences the the
sciences that engaged in the observation
so Hinkle escribes finger on something
very important here all right so he goes
on enemy says they're a peculiar
quantitative qualitative antithesis thus
becomes one of magnitude and so this is
here gagan Zots now if you know thesis
antithesis synthesis put all that aside
just means an opposition or a
contradiction of sorts so the games apps
the antithesis here is one of magnitude
which for Hagel is you know not
particularly interesting and loses its
grasp on many of the real aspects that
we're looking at so he says there are
rise laws of this kind this is you know
sort of typical example of the kind of
things that people were interested in in
his time and I think in our own we're
sensibility and irritability see
inverse ratio of their magnitude so as
the one increases the other decreases or
better taking the magnitude itself as
the content as its smallness decreases
so what is there what is it you know
what kind of thing are we working with
there let's let's ask that very broad
question an inverse relation so any
inverse relation I think most of the
people watching us you know you know
what that is right away but just in case
when we say the things vary inversely
we're saying that as you increase the
one you decrease the other they're
connected there's a relation between
them of that sort so that you know to
the degree that you raised this one this
one should go now think of the for
example a zero what we call a zero-sum
game let's pick the easiest one that
there is two kids dividing up a piece of
gum their parents is given one of them a
piece of gum and said you need to break
this into you know equal parts or fare
cards and then let your brother or
sister to side or friend right yeah I
bring off you know part that's bigger
for me and tending it for myself the
other person gets less and vice versa
right lots of things of that nature now
what he says here main strike you as a
bit paradoxical at first but he goes on
to say the inverse relations can relieve
or inverse proportions can really just
be turned into direct proportions you
just have to change your perspective on
how so well here's an example let's take
a specific content of this law as the
size of the hole it increases the more
what it is filled with decreases okay so
it looks like we're we're contrasting
inverse you know we have an inverse
relation there as one thing goes up the
other thing goes goes down right he says
this inverse relation can equally be
changed into a direct relation and
express them this way
as the size of the hole increases the
the size of the hole increases in direct
ratio to the amount take it away take
away 5 cups for the dirt now you get a 5
cup size hole in take away 5 bucket
loader buckets worth of dirt you've got
a much bigger hole you know the more you
take away the less there is there but
it's less in a sort of illusory sense
right because you talked just as well
about there being more there more hole
and then we can do these sort of verbal
games but Hagel is getting at something
he says look there's really nothing
going on here if you want to say that as
your ability increases sensibility
decreases you're really just talking
about you know magnitudes that are you
know being connected together this way
and you're not seeing a tautology you're
saying is one thing increases the other
thing increases as well there could be
the lack of sensibility that's that's
increasing so he says here we go just as
a whole and what fills in it has taken
away are qualitatively opposed but what
is real in them and it's specific
quantity is one of the same in both
similarly increase of magnitude and
decrease of smallness are the same thing
they're meaningless antithesis amounts
to a tautology so are the organic
movements alike indivisible and their
real content and in their magnitude
which is the magnitude of that being so
what he's saying here is when you're
measuring what do you think to be
distinct things in organic beings by
looking at them in terms of what is
mathema Thaisa below can be reduced to
quantity quantitative distinction and
then quantitative relation you're really
just measuring the same thing from
different aspects so you're doing a
tautology you're not adding any new
knowledge to anything they give a bunch
of examples here some of which are you
know in certain respects I think a bit
off-base let's take the example of three
he says number three remains the same
quantity whether it is taken positively
or negatively if i increase the three to
four both the positive and the negative
have become for just and here's the
analogy just as the South Pole of a
magnet is exactly as strong as its north
pole or a positive electricity or an
acid is exactly as strong as its
negative or the base on which it is now
in a certain sense Hagel that is right
and he's made two assertions there that
negative 3 and positive 3 really end up
the mounting to the same thing if we
think in terms of what we call it
mathematics the absolute value that
that's quite true it may not be true in
other contexts okay go you might be
getting you a bad example here but you
know when we think about how he's trying
to frame this we have increase from
three to four likewise if we have other
things that are that are connected with
each other in similar proportions like
you know the strength of an acid to the
strength of the base that would have to
cancel it out or the strength of
positive and negative electricity
generated by you know one dynamic system
or you know the strength of a particular
magnet imagining that we're making an
electromagnet with a positive and
negative he is actually technically
correct where's the application of this
to this stuff over here that's not quite
so clear from these examples so you know
he's saying the bold can be range is a
little intention next action in all that
source oh that's not extremely helpful
for understanding what he is trying to
say we're going to see in the next
paragraphs a little bit of
clarification but i do want to dwell on
this a bit he is saying this that when
we try to formulate laws that apply to
these three factors these three
fundamental aspects of organic being
what we typically end up doing is losing
sight of what it is that we're supposed
to be measuring and so maybe introduce
quantitative distinctions why because
that helps us you know too many respects
wrap our heads around it and we had a
great hopes that it will allow us to
manipulate the the things that we're
dealing with right and we can do a
certain extent you know you think about
advances in medicine in dealing with
organic systems that's all going to be
on this side pretty much but the living
thing is not a matter of mathematics
it's a matter of qualitative
distinctions in which these things all
are inter penetrating with each other
and so this loses its hold on that and
the law is only grasping an aspect of
the organic being rather than the
totality or the essence of the organic p
you